all right
bree bree uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
uh right outside of seattle in
washington
what was your childhood like you had
both your parents
not really mostly my dad raised me
where was mom
i've been spoken she lived she's from
spokane and
she was just around when she wanted to
be
were drugs as part of her life or
something like that
yeah
yeah
did you get to know your mom at all or
she was gone most of the time
i got to know her when she wanted to but
we always went to her parents house
i got a um sister
she knows her like you know my when my
parents got divorced she wouldn't let my
dad have my sister because
it wasn't his biological daughter so she
kept my sister
so my sister knows her more than we do
but when i was like 16 17 i went to go
live with her
and then from there i just
came out here
how would you describe your childhood
it was not bad it was pretty good
very family oriented
because my dad has five brothers and for
four brothers and five sisters
so he's very family oriented he's
filipino
so they just
every family's everything
how far did you go in school
high school
completed high school
nothing after that
and then how did you get into doing sex
work
i was working two jobs i was getting
tired and
i was
like well it was a boyfriend i met
and he was from out from vallejo the bay
and
he had other friends that had girls that
did it and i was just getting tired of
working and waiting
for money so
we just
told him let's do it let's try it
was he a pimp
no no he's so dope
so we learned it together
and you've been doing it how
long off and onsen let's see
for at least five years
yeah
off and on because um i went to jail for
like almost two years
and so you know
took a break for that
but then
came out here
and still doing it
it's not as but in the beginning it was
fun
the fast money everything it was fun in
the beginning now it's just like
survival
not as fun
it's like
i don't know how to explain it
it's not it's not really fun no more it
was fun in the beginning are drugs a
part of your life
yes and no
like if someone else is doing it yeah
i'm a party with them
but if it was up to me like if i'm by
myself and not with the crowd that does
it then no
just weed yeah
but if i'm around people with other
people i do it then you know influence
what kind of things
does a girl need to know doing this kind
of work
there's all kinds of dangers out there a
lot of
yeah
you really got to be on your toes
they may people may seem don't ever do
drugs with them
don't ever when they just get a party
don't do that [ __ ] with them
because it just turns the whole
atmosphere around with them then they're
gonna try to control you
try to pay you like that
and they're gonna use it against you if
you had guys
you know
kidnap you or
beat you and all that kind of one time
when i first came out here and i was on
fig well first like the first couple it
was probably like the first month i was
on fig
that i had like the worst week ever
um
a car pulled up you know like on the
corner pulled up on the corner blocking
me and then another car pulled up and
the guy jumped out and won the cars and
threw me in the other car
and so we were going down fig and like
when we were at the light i started
taking my shoes off when he saw me
trying to open the door when it was a
red light
i i was about to jump out when he saw me
jump out he just ran the red line just
gassed up and then next thing i know is
them there's another guy like picking me
up off the ground i was like laid out
flat like this
it was
i probably wouldn't because he snatched
my phone
everything you know every like contact i
have he took everything from me
so i probably wasn't going to be able to
get out from there
and then
i think like a night or two after that
another guy got came out with a gun and
forced me in the car
i guess we drove all the way to
dropped on the freeway and drove all the
way to carson and zip tied me and then
left me there
that's like the worst week ever
did you worked with the tent
no not really
like
the person that brought me out here
i was um
he was going back and forth to spokane
you know the moxie pills he was bringing
those out there that's how i met him
through my friends out there
and then i started running back and
forth the money and the pills back and
forth for him and then that's how i got
out
here i just never left i like california
though
because some of the people are just
nasty
has
prostitution in
washington state and
in los angeles compare
out here is more cheap
this is like
like like i'm gonna say like back
out here you got the streets you can
walk down
back home and they you know there's
streets like that but
it's not very common like to be walking
on the street to catch a date it's more
internet and everything
because i i was you want to say i was
working just the internet when i was
back home back in washington
because you know it's always raining out
there and everything so it's more
internet than it is walking the streets
or you go to a bar but it's like it's
more harder that way out here you can
walk down the street anybody will try to
pick you up and
try to pay you cheap
for a date do you recall your very first
time doing it
yeah the first time i caught a date on
fig
i damn near cried
it was two mexicans and they wanted to
only pay me
i think was it 40
40 and 40.
i just i couldn't like you know because
i was so used to just a hundred dollars
and then when come out here it's like 40
60. if that and you got to argue with
them do you even get
sixty eighty dollars
do you have children i got one i got one
child i got a boy he just turned 13 last
june
damn near as tall as me have you been
raising him
i paid for everything that he did like
you know everything he needs i go back i
go back and forth every few weeks i go
back and forth home stay a week or two
he's rare in uh um in spokane in spokane
spokane washington
what kind of emotions do you deal with
kind of wet what kind of emotions do you
deal with from doing this kind of work
does it make you depressed or angry or
honest probably more depressed
because
it's like they degrade you
because they're paying you so it's like
they give them the right to degrade you
and talk down to you
and then you know i don't know it was
just like out here is like a different
crowd like all the guys like you know
at home it's more like
you want to you don't really talk about
it you don't really tell them like you
do that kind of work because it's like
you're more embarrassed that you do it
out here it's just it don't matter
you don't you don't care they don't care
it don't matter
but it you know
it's like they treat you different you
know it's just weird it's weird to me
because
back home you you know you keep it more
quiet about it
you don't want people to know because
then you know
it's more
you know you might run into somebody you
know
and you don't want them to know about it
then you're you know
you got to hide it from people you don't
like your close family and friends out
here it's just it's not it's different
just like
it don't matter
you really don't
is it a lonely life
yeah a little bit
yeah because i'll be by myself a lot
it gets boring
because you really don't have nobody but
yourself
and the people who call you
what do you think of the men that pick
you up
some of them are really cool and some of
them are just like you know
disgusting i hate it when a fat person
picks me up because they smell the worst
it's like they don't shower or nothing
what's the hardest part of
doing this kind of work for you
the hardest part
probably when
it's not like that it's not really hard
anymore it's like i'm so used to it you
to all the dangers
probably yeah you could that's what
that's when i came out here
i like you know you got to be on your
toes so you can't really
if you don't feel right the minute you
jump in you you got to get out because
you never know if you don't if i don't
feel right by just talking to you i'm
not going
and it could have been a good one it
could have been a bad one but if i don't
feel right i'm just not going to do it
you've got to follow your intuition
you really do because if you don't
that's when the bad things happen
what do you think most people that
are from outside this world don't
don't understand about girls that do
this kind of work
they don't understand is just you know
they're doing it to take care of
themselves take care of their family
it's no different than someone standing
on the corner selling fruit
to me it's like the same thing you're
out there trying to make money to
support your family
but it's people see it more as
some people see it as disgusting
not so much disgusting like you know
degrading i don't even know the word for
it
is like
no good you know
but i understand
but they really don't know what we go
through until they've been in that
situation
do you think you're addicted to this
lifestyle
yeah
because it's fast money yeah it's gonna
be hard to put that down right
it really is it really is because you're
so used to getting them it comes fast
just as fast as it comes just as fast as
it goes
so you get you get addicted to
you know i can go over here and sit
outside for an hour and make 100 200
then go sit at a job and work all day
long and you got to wait till payday to
get your money
it's like you get paid right then and
there
it's just more a little bit more
dangerous because you don't know what's
going to happen
what was the best time of your life
what was the best time of my life
probably when when i first started it
was fun because the money was coming in
so fast just
i was
blowing it so fast
buying everything my son wanted anything
he needed
now it's just like when you need
something it's like i gotta go to work
and
see what i can do
it's not coming as fast as you used to
it's different
it really is different
but it is addicting because you can't
stop because if you need the money it's
fast
then working a nine to five nine to five
you just gotta sit and wait for your
paycheck and even then it's gone by the
time you get paid
working this way is like
you work and get your money right then
and then you can buy whatever you want
with it
when you get when you get a paycheck you
know
it's basically already gone
because you're working all the week
hours and then when you get paid you got
to pay this you got to pay that i guess
in a way it's the same thing
but
you get extra i guess it's extra money
because a paycheck is pretty much gone
on bills and everything
when you work you can just work if you
want to go party or something
when you get a paycheck it's like you
gotta pay this first and this that first
and then then you can party and you
might not even have nothing afterwards
but if i could work
i'd still work and do this on the side
it's crazy because
before i started doing this i was
working as a cna in a um
in a nursing home like a sister living
home
and then
started doing this
you feel like doing this kind of work
kind of prevents you from finding love
in your life
a little bit
kind of
it's just like you know
when you do find someone they either got
accepted or
help you get out and either even then
they can't even help you
because they can't provide what you need
because you're so addicted to that money
and what you want
you know you can just go out there and
go do a date and go get what you want
if you're with somebody it's like
you can't go out
and make your money
because they don't want you to
then you lose your love
because you can't stop
how many of your
clients are married do you think
more than half of them
a lot of them are
most of them are
yeah that's crazy
what's the one yeah most of them are
what has that taught you about
men doing this kind of work
um not all of them are loyal to their
wives
they're cheating all the time
because a lot of them will tell you
don't call me don't call me wait till i
call you
you get me in trouble then i can't come
then i'm like thinking in my head like
if that was my husband i'd kill him
hell yeah what advice would you give to
a young girl who's thinking about doing
this kind of work
don't do it
because you're gonna end up
either on drugs or you can't stop
don't do it
go to school
and
however i wouldn't live i wouldn't tell
them to do it
because you don't really get nothing out
of it by the time
you want to stop you're old you can't
even
really you know by the time you want to
stop you should have been set in your
career
you can't just go to school at like 50
and then decide you
you could but you couldn't you know
you can't go to school and then
expect to have a good job because now
you're gonna have to work the rest of
your life
the only thing that's not so good about
this is you're not gonna get a 401k
as you would if you went to school and
got a real job
being educated and you'll get a job
it's interesting how many because we are
not going to have a retirement you know
you will if you go to school and do that
job
you know you're going to have the 401k
and retirement we're not
our retirements whatever we save
more likely it's not going to be nothing
because we blow money so fast because as
fast as it comes as fast as it goes
it's interesting that
of all the people i've interviewed
i don't think any of them have told me
they're really saving money
no they're making good money it seems
you're making good money but
you're not cuz you're not
thinking about saving it
you know what you got and then you know
you know most people want like a 400
purse that's what i used to spend my
money on purses and [ __ ]
and then you know most of the time you
gotta get a room so you're sitting you
know your money's gonna go quick as fast
as you get as fast as it's been spent
it really is
you're not thinking about saving it no
you're not
we really ain't
and bree what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
in this
yeah hold it
i'm through i'm gonna be 32 in a couple
months
what have you learned in 32 years
what's the most important thing you've
learned
you really got to follow your instincts
if you don't follow your instincts
you're really going to get [ __ ] off
because there's times where i was like i
should have listened i should have
listened
i should have listened to them and you
know
now you're making me think real hard
i don't know if i got
if i was to mentor somebody i'll tell
them
i would try to keep them away from it
because it's you know once you get that
taste of it you're not going to want to
stop
you really ain't
because the money comes fast but it's
not going to always be there
you're going to get burnt out
see now it's like a to me like
like like i said it's not fun no more
it's just like a drag sometimes
because the people you got to deal with
who you gotta deal with
it's just like
like like when you're sick and don't
wanna go to work
and it's dangerous
it really is
something i'm telling you sometimes when
i gotta go meet somebody it's like i
don't want to deal with them i really
don't feel like it
but then you know you got to because you
need that money
i wouldn't i wouldn't tell nobody to go
do it
i really wouldn't
all right bree thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck out there
yeah because i grew up the way i grew up
i know my father's disappointed in me
because i was raised better than that
i wouldn't recommend it
really when
you're going to lose a lot of people
that are close to you
are you still in contact with your
family
and they know you're doing this
they do but they don't talk about it
my dad i was really close to my dad i
was a daddy's girl
and he don't even talk to me he does but
it doesn't
and it hurts
because i know i know how it feels
and i actually finally realized
it's not so much like
he's disappointed me because i was
raised better than that but then i
understand like he must feel like he
failed
you know your daughter's doing this when
she grew up like this i had everything i
wanted he worked hard there was times he
had three jobs
and then to for me to end up like this
it's like he failed and raising me
so it's like it's like hard
no you're gonna lose your family
you really huh
i think
i don't mean to grab it
that's a touchy subject
it really is
yeah shane's a big
big one
it is
it's more like
when i you know he still speaks to me
it's not like i lost him all the way
he's just not the same like he used to
be
it really isn't
and now that i think i'm telling you now
i think about it it's not so much as
that he failed and raising me
it's how he feels you know he failed
it's like i mean you know he's not just
not so much disappointed
it's just like
it must make i think i'm i think it's
like more like he
worked so hard to raise me to give me
what i wanted
and now that
i'm grown and the way i was raised
it's like
i should've never been like this
and i understand now but
it's like you it's like
it's like you lose that closeness with
your family
it's like
they don't really want to see you like
that
i don't know it's just hard
because my um for longest time ever we
didn't know my mom my mom was doing it
and i didn't she didn't start until like
we were like
i don't know
i don't know it's just weird because
they talk so much down on my mom because
we see her out we saw around the streets
one time on this on the street called
sprague in spokane
it's mostly like you know the women you
see out there is mostly drug addicts
so when they're drug addict it's like
uh that's what they're doing they're
working for drugs
so
this is crazy
but yeah
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story
i wish you the best of luck thank you
thanks especially it's crazy though
you